the fda is expected to authorize
pfizer's cova 19 vaccine for kids
between the ages of 12
and 15 this week this after a march
clinical trial revealed that pfizer's
vaccine had 100
efficacy for teenagers so what do
parents need to know before vaccinating
their children
fox news medical contributor and author
of the brand new book
panic attack dr nicole sapphire hey dr
sapphire
good morning ainsley good morning what
do parents need to know should we get
our kids between those ages vaccinated
hey ainsley just like any vaccination at
that age of course you want to have that
conversation with the pediatrician as
there are risk
and benefits to everything 12 to 15 year
olds have very similar immunobiologies
to young adults
so they are affected by copin 19 the
same way they also are demonstrating
some getting that long covid so
especially if you have a high risk child
who may be overweight may have asthma
definitely have that conversation with
your pediatrician i don't really think
this push is going to get us to that
hurt immunity that everyone's crying for
in the media i think that we're much
closer to herd immunity and
we don't even need to possibly extend
the vaccination efforts to children to
get us to hurt immunity
but i do think that some children are
severely affected by this virus so it is
important to have a set
safe and efficacious vaccine available
for them all right good deal
you wrote an op-ed uh it's uh called
biden it's titled biden versus big
pharma here's why
waiving patent rights on coveted
vaccines is a big mistake
explain that so angela you know
president biden during his campaign
trail said that if there was a
successful coveted vaccine that he would
give away the patents so that other
countries could benefit from it but i'll
tell you ainsley i think this really
sets a dangerous precedent
because the reason the us is a global
leader in pharmaceutical innovation
is because we have such strong
intellectual property rights and because
we have free market
if you give this away then what is going
to make those
big pharmaceutical companies actually
want to continue to innovate
and to be honest this is really just
virtue signaling this does very little
to actually help nations in need right
now
the good news is these pharmaceutical
giants have already pledged billions of
doses
in addition to what the united states
and other countries are pledging
billions of doses to these countries so
really by
saying that they support giving away the
intellectual property rights
again virtue signaling doesn't really do
anything tangible to help these
struggling countries
and it accepts a dangerous precedent by
chipping away these
these property rights that are so
crucial to our innovation if you start
doing that now
where will the government stop will they
do away with the private entities
altogether
that's what i get concerned about well
you make some great points in this
article you congratulate operation
uh warp speed and you talk about the
efforts that we've done here in the u.s
to have
such a surplus of these vaccines and how
we're helping other countries like india
it's a it's a good read so everyone go
check it out foxnews.com nicole sapphire
dr sapphire thank you